oui
les automobilistes qui sillonnent
régulièrement l'autoroute 55 connaissent
bien le moulin à laine d'ulverton
pourtant bien peuples ont déjà visité
[Musique]
l'attraction touristique du coin le
moulin est pourtant riche en histoires
c'est un moulin pour filer la laine donc
à l'époque et filer la laine pour lire
pour les environs les gens pouvaient
venir faire filer leur laine ici ça
grossit naturellement
et ça ne fonctionnait beaucoup durant la
fin jusqu'à la fin du 19e siècle début
du 20e siècle
après ça avec l'avènement des plus
grosses filature à sherbrooke à
drummondville
malheureusement une une période que ça a
commencé à descendre puis s'affirmer en
en fait la vie du moulin en tant que tel
a duré agron sentent la collection du
moulin contient des machines uniques au
canada des équipements complexes dont
les secrets de fonctionnement ont
disparu avec le départ des derniers
employés
on est encore là la déchiqueteuse on a
encore la carte 2 on a encore la fileuse
la machine date de 1936 il reste prudent
mais c'est très très très rare
quelques filature aux états unis qu'un
respect au canada
[Musique]
certains éléments ont aussi été recréée
pour ajouter au cachet historique du
site comme ce pont couvert
[Musique]
l'endroit attire aussi son lot de
marcheurs est à peu près une quinzaine
d'actes 5 km de sentiers donc les gens
peuvent flâner le long de la rivière
une promenade au cours de laquelle le
calme ne sera interrompue que par lebel
membre imitant n'a pas pris une
quinzaine de moutons
plusieurs personnes qui mènent
mont-louis est ce que vous vous gardez
est ce que vous faites une production à
partir des moutons vous avez non
malheureusement fait presseur c'est pour
elle un en démonstration et on le dit on
est des petits moutons c'est que les
enfants aiment bien bien seul et nourrir
c'est agréable
attraction encore méconnu du grand
public le seul moulin à laine au canada
fera peut-être se démarquer en ces temps
difficiles en cette année de qu'ovide
c'est à peu près le seul indice hull
city est ouvert dans la région dans la
grande région
donc si vous voulez vous promener dans
les sentiers souvenirs visiter un site
historique si c'est vraiment la place
pour aller ici fanny lachance packet
radio canada albertaine